apparently people want to go see the
ruins of the Titanic they want to spend
about a quarter million dollars per
ticket most rich people don't do things
like this most rich people if they're
smart live lives of boring abundance
boring abundance they have a lot and
life's dull and every now and then
people do have to die like this because
it shows people that wanting to have an
experience
in life wanting to feel something
especially when you're incredibly
wealthy is always a mistake
you must live with the misery of your
wealth you must live with how much it
dislocates you and disconnects you from
Humanity you must not fight it